all right you guys it's Friday and it's
time for another movie retrospective
this is again a little bit of a deep cut
I feel like yeah on a pretty
underappreciated this one yeah we've
done some Stuart Gordon movies before
obviously we did reanimate her we did
Dagon yeah
this is one that doesn't really get a
lot of love I guess it's got kind of a
little bit of a cult following now but
it's not one of his better known ones it
actually came out bit later it was
directed DVD it's kind of from a
low-rent sort of production company yeah
doesn't matter though it's still
Geoffrey Kong yeah it's like but however
it's much better than its pedigree would
suggest yeah
and actually we saw it on shudder it's
on shudder right now and I was like oh I
forgot all about this movie and people
have been recommending it to me so I
actually went and watched it now the
weird thing was that I didn't look at
what year it came out until after we
watched it because I was thinking that
it came out like either a little bit
before or a little bit after like from
beyond so I was thinking it came out
like in the mid 80s no it came out in
1995 yeah but you wouldn't really know
that it's not because it's crappy
looking it's just because her yeah
Geoffrey come see he looked exactly the
same age yeah he didn't look any older
so I was like so I guess that was like
what I was thinking in my head that it's
like because he didn't look yeah I
looked he looked very young stuff and
it's real weird to think just a couple
years later like two years later he did
frighteners yeah and frighteners is on a
totally different level the thing about
my life right I did to you and it's like
and yeah we did a we did a review that's
it yeah a while back that was one of the
first yeah did I think that's another
underappreciated one this movie like I
said directed by Stuart Gordon written
by Denis Paoli the screenwriter who also
reanimate ER and from beyond this is
actually sort of based on an HP
Lovecraft story it's based on the one
called The Outsider which is actually
one of his best regarded short stories
but really the only element in the movie
that you know is kind of comes from the
story is the thing about somebody I mean
it's written in the first person so he's
writing about somebody that
like been in this castle dungeon thing
he doesn't even know it's a dungeon but
he's been in this castle his whole life
he's never spoken he's never heard
anybody speak he's never seen another
human being and all this other kind of
seven that he comes out at the end and
he's like a monster yeah or other people
perceive him as a monster so that's sort
of a sort of idea of this one but it's
kind of not exactly the same so it's a
very loose adaptation yeah the
interesting thing too about this one is
that Stuart Gordon is kind of known for
doing like I said reanimate her and
stuff like kind of horror comedies sort
of or like over top of the over - yeah
so this one is oddly serious yeah yeah
this is actually a pretty serious movie
not really any humor in it um Jeffrey
Combs I think this is the only time I've
ever seen him play a normal person yeah
yeah second normal character this one
kind of has to me a head like a like a
Frankenstein feel Dracula more like
Phantom of the Opera RAM of the Opera it
was like a classic horror movie yeah um
and it was kind of like a Quasimodo yeah
yeah you know this one's pretty rare I
don't think we should spoil all the
elements yeah we won't um it's it's a
good it's a good one to see if you
hadn't seen it and I didn't even know
the movie existed until recently yeah I
was in that well in 95 96 I was in
Boston partying it up I I really didn't
know what Jeffrey Combs was doing at
that time was until about a year later
you know then I saw a couple years later
that I saw frighteners yeah and
fragrance is really good to people if
you haven't seen that go back and watch
our frighteners review and even if you
saw frighteners and didn't like it
there's a couple different cuts of that
movie and the the cut that's on the
blu-rays fantastic I like it it's longer
I think then yeah yeah but this one is
like like I said you know every other
movie I've seen Jeffery comes in he is
placed like a very mannered character
like a weirdo in this one he plays like
a regular dude and I was and he's
astoundingly good at it yeah
particularly he's very good at the
couple scenes were like he goes to the
bar to pick up the prostitute and he
gets
faced yeah and he's like he plays a
really good drunk yeah I also really
liked Barbara Crampton as in this to you
guys she doesn't get naked I'm sorry
well she did like she did any other ones
yeah but so they play husband and wife
and they're kind of estranged which they
you find out the reason like later on in
the movie but so they're just kind of
like at each other's throats all the
time and it is like scarily realistic
like they play very well off each other
you can really believe these two are a
married couple and he like [ __ ] up big
time and she can't forgive him and
they're just like screaming at each
other and like this whole coldness
everything so it's like a really really
good performance the two of them give
like they work really well together and
you know so like I said they've been in
a lot of Stuart Gordon movies you know
with each other yeah it's a it's weird
that this movie is related to from
beyond and dagon yeah and reanimate er
coz the tone is totally different even
the same actor is nothing but the tone
is just like classic horror it's like a
gothic like a classic God for it's and
it's kind of Italian I mean it's shot in
Italy so it almost it looks like it
almost shot like a giallo type movie and
it has some jell-o type elements in it
yeah here's the the genesis of it is
very funny because so the story goes
Stuart Gordon walks into the office of
Charles band who is the producer for
full moon pictures which if you didn't
know did your favorite transfers you
also did like the puppet master movie
favorite transfers upon seeing transfers
with modernised transfers was transfers
one was a piece of [ __ ] well that's I
can't believe I bought that oh I know
well it was you you had like
rose-colored memory but yeah so this is
the same production company it's a very
cheap Jack type production company there
and they're kind of known for that so
you wouldn't think so apparently Stuart
Gordon walks into Charles band's office
and Charles band has a poster in his
office that says Castle freak on it
and it has like this monster that's
being whipped by a woman in search
stewart's like what's that and he's like
oh I don't know it's just a poster oh
that's not a movie or anything it's just
you know what you want to use it sure
it's like yeah that I can I use that
concept they're like yeah as long as it
doesn't castle on a freak in it good you
know go to town so so there was a poster
for a non-existent movie and Stuart
Gordon liked the idea of it so he's sort
of tied it in with the whole HP
Lovecraft thing basically what happened
Charles banned I guess making knockoff
DVD horror movies like you know I think
he made Glee's and stuff like that -
like what I remember that so he made
those um I guess that pays pretty well
because you know the castle in Italy
where this was shot that's his Wow a lot
of his movies were shot there cuz he's
like cuz [ __ ] if I had a castle I've got
all my movies they're all ya the premise
of this one is a guy I think he
inherited the castle right yeah from
like a there's a relative you didn't
know it was an answer moves his family
into there he actually plans on
liquidating everything out of the estate
yeah you know there already has a staff
has a lady that takes care of it and
it's a creepy old castle and turns out
there's a monster in the castle yeah
well any fear they think it's a monster
and then they they figure it out don't
want to spoil too much about it yeah
I've seen it this is kind of a rare
movie but you can watch it for free on
shudder it's good though it's strange
because like I said this has a very
serious tone yeah that tells very
different it's just you know it's this
broken family that is you know they're
trying to get their [ __ ] back together
he's trying to get his [ __ ] back
together like I said he's a recovering
alcoholic and you know and he [ __ ] up
big-time back in the past is why I can't
forgive him blah blah so he inherits
this castle from this aunt who happened
to be a duchess she croaks leaves him
the castle because he's her only living
relative so they move in there they're
not gonna stay there but they're just
like living there until you know they
can sell it or liquidate it or whatever
and then they later come to discover
that there is is he's not exactly a
monster he's like a deformed guy he's
like Quasimodo
type thing and he's been like chained
down the basement like the Duchess kept
him down there
yeah its whole life say it's weird and
yeah did bad things to him while I was
down there and you find out why and it's
just you know yeah he has various
appendages lubed and some other stuff
and you know she had some issues yes
vert and why she kept him down there and
stuff like that but I I feel like one
thing about this this movie cost
$500,000 to make yeah that's what I
heard yeah it's like nothing so like I
said they had the location cuz Charles
bands like hey just film it of my
Italian castle like you so they filmed
it there and that goes a long way toward
making it not look cheap you know what I
mean
the makeups pretty good uh yeah actually
the titular castle freak yeah um he
looks pretty damn good yeah and there
and if you're into that like I said this
is a Stuart Gordon movie so there's
gonna be titties yeah it's gonna be gore
yeah like I said Barbara Crampton
doesn't get naked but a couple other
people do um and you do get to see the
castle freak bite someone's tit off yeah
which nice yeah there's some disturbing
stuff in there oh yeah and what what's
weird about the movie it's kind of a
mixed bag it's good and bad and guess
you could say in a certain way is that
it doesn't really look like a 90s movie
at all it looks like that's what I mean
I didn't think it was shot like like a
high-quality 80s movie yeah oh my god
it's hard to believe that frighteners is
two years later because it looks like
it's 20-30 years apart in terms of the
way frighteners is filmed wait oh yeah
you know it's just but you know it's
good it has its own atmosphere I read
somewhere that and like I said when we
first watched this I didn't know what
year it came out and I was like shocked
when I found out that it came out in
1995 for Christ's sake I was like no I
was thinking it was like 80 yeah kind of
what it looks like but um I saw somebody
say I was reading a review of it earlier
and they said something to the effect of
this looks like a remake that was done
in the 80s of like an old movie like
from the 50s or series because it's very
it's structured very much like you said
like Frankenstein or Phantom of the
Opera
yeah or you know what's always Emoto in
it I can't remember I can't believe I
can remember Tom it's like so it's very
much in that sort of Jarrett um yeah you
can tell that's exactly the kind of
movie they're making right so but so
it's like the Lovecraft connection is
really not there I mean this Lovecraft
story like I said the outsider which was
written in the 20s 1926 I think it was
it was his most Edgar Allen Poe esque
story which he actually said at the time
it is very polite so you get that kind
of thing this is not like the Cthulhu
Mythos
you know crazy out there type [ __ ] with
tentacles and everything this is very
much in the Gothic tradition much more
like I said like an Edgar Allan Poe
story really than a Lovecraft story but
unlike ice it's just so it was just so
weird to me today you're right it has
kind of there's an element of like to
follow the house of Usher's yeah it's
all that it's that kind of [ __ ] you know
Cask of Amontillado it's it's very much
like it gave me the same kind of vibe as
like Roger Corman's Edgar Allan Poe
adaptations except not as colorful as
that it's almost kind of like a gothic
melodrama like with a monster in it yeah
because a lot of the [ __ ] with gore with
a lot of gore yeah and some disturbing
your section rape scenes and yeah it's
kind of upsetting you know so it's you
know I'm just saying if you don't like
saying that about adays standards it
yeah it's not a huge deal but I feel
like you know if you've seen like a
[ __ ] Serbian film or you know what's
like irreversible or inside or whatever
if you really mess me up we got to do
this one Frankenstein's army that kind
of messed me up even as an adult and the
stuff that Frankenstein was making for
the the Russians I guess yeah the
Russians and the Nazis he was making
stuff for both of them yeah it's hard to
tell but you know the thing about it
it's like it's not you you can just
watch it like I said as pretty much just
like a gothic straight-ahead monster
movie but there's also kind of some
deeper [ __ ] in there about you know that
he draws kind of like a parallel between
Jeffrey Combs's character whose name is
John Riley in case I didn't mention that
and his kind of crumbling
relationship with his family and like
his fuck-ups and everything like that
and they kind of tie it in with the
story of like the monster and how he
came to be down there and [ __ ] like that
so there's kind of an interesting
there's like a deeper element there if
you want to explore that you don't have
to like I said it's just kind of a gory
monster movie to a little bit of a slow
burn at the beginning but like I said
that was that's like the classics though
they did that too right but it was very
good at like establishing character and
like I said the interesting thing too is
that you know other than the family's
daughter whose name is Rebecca she's a
blind girl you know the to the the
husband and wife at the center who's
named her John and Susan and it's
Barbara Crampton and Jeffrey Combs it's
a lot about you know the two of them and
it's interesting because Jeffrey Combs
his character is kind of a [ __ ] I mean
he's not like the he's not heroic no um
he's not so he's almost like an antihero
type away and I mean Barbara Crampton
'he's character cuz at first you don't
know like why she's acting the way she's
like why is she being such a [ __ ] to
holy crap it was but then later you find
out and it's like understandable but so
this whole time it's like these to UM
plant and they're just like at each
other's throats all the time and you're
not entirely sure why at first so but
like I said so a lot of the characters
are not super like they're relatable but
they're not necessarily likeable until
you learn more about them like later on
good now that you bring that up about
the main character not being really too
good not really being a good guy yeah
kind of being a [ __ ] makes me think we
got a do tusk man turns another man into
a walrus
well see I'm pretty sure that's like a
Kevin Smith movie yeah and he always
makes his weird ass like he started out
making pretty normal ones like back and
they like chasing Amy it's definitely
this is the same because I'm pretty sure
I didn't look it up so I was a nerd ass
moving
yeah but he didn't he made like yoga who
I was like thinking about that for like
a whole day afterwards I'm like man well
you know I was trying to figure out what
he meant by all that I think I got it
figured out we need to do an analysis I
mean if that is indeed if
he wrote the scripture that I need some
of that weed that he's got it would help
me with my writing no it's probably
giving me more about mares it's a yeah
it's on Netflix it's like actually Sean
and Eric who were on our Halloween show
they recommended it which is why I
watched it that night but yeah it's
batshit insane ya know I don't know
we're talking about tusk not this one
yeah this one's on this one this one's
case it's like a classic horror movie
with some gore and stuff and tusk is
just twisted what we do do I'm gonna do
an analysis of tossed I got a super
movie I got to see it a couple more
times I'll figure it out all angles Aria
yeah I'll try to figure there's some
kind of some kind of a having to do with
the tears at the end are we talking
about the tears of a man or a tears of a
walrus there's some kind of symbolism
yeah something having to do with man oh
man as a walrus but he's trippin - you
know but maybe he was he was getting
high and listening - I am The Walrus was
like yeah yeah I don't know Eureka
that's a movie and it is we'll see when
we started watching it like all I knew
was the title I didn't know who directed
it I know it is bad or nothing I'm
watching I'm going what the [ __ ] yeah
yeah I didn't like that movie but I have
to know more about it she was nasty I
gotta get off this subject that we just
you know fer yeah for future reference
if you want to do it but yeah so you
know like I said this is one that kind
of you know just to get a little bit
under the radar people obviously because
Stuart Gordon made free animator and
from beyond those pretty much the two
that everybody talks about because those
are classics so this one gets a little
bit it's you know sort of pushed under
but I think that if you like a lot of
the Gothic elements I mean if you like
Jeffrey Combs like I said and wanted see
him play it completely straight
yeah normal person role not a likable
person really not really until the end
because he has the you know
the redemption arc and everything like
that but you know I was like amazed I'm
watching him like man that dude can act
his [ __ ] it is I like Jeffery now
like that team that made those movies
from bond from God and all that and I
didn't know about this and so it was
good to see this one it's a set it's in
there it is it is a different tone very
different it's a different movie but but
if you're into [ __ ] you know exactly
what it's getting at it's getting that
Dracula Frankenstein follow the House of
Usher casts some on Thiago you know it's
a pose with classic with a weird gory
because that's like there's a lot of sex
in this like I said from yeah you know
Jeffrey Combs you know that that whole
thing there's a thing with like his wife
won't have sex with him and stuff and
then there's the whole thing with
there's a prostitute there's yeah and
then there's like the thing with the
monster wanting to rape women cuz he's
never had and then a monster trying to
rape the little daughter right and
there's all kind of [ __ ] up [ __ ] in it
there's no like that family died of some
weird Freudian jan there's a lot of
weird [ __ ] going on there so yeah if you
like Stuart Gordon's other stuff and you
haven't seen it cuz like I said I only
just recently saw this I'd heard of it I
just never got around to it
but it's you know it's a different thing
than his other ones his more famous ones
yeah I it was kind of forgotten but it
is good yeah it's definitely worth
saying I mean it honestly he made a
bunch more like he made one called dolls
which also has Jeffrey Combs in it which
I don't think I've ever seen you guys
see that one if I did if I did I forgot
about it we'll see them you know he's
made several other ones but of the other
ones that I've seen you know other than
the two big ones I actually really
really liked this a lot it's kind of
it's creepy it's kind of disturbing you
know the the castle set is amazing so
you know check it out like I said if you
have a shudder it's on there at the
moment you might be able to find it it
does it did come out on blu-ray I
believe in 2013 the interesting thing is
that for a long time there was only an
r-rated cut which had some of the nasty
[ __ ] cut out but when it was released to
DVD or to blu-ray they
accidentally on purpose released the
Unrated version and yet they still rated
it are so so is that the cut we saw yes
so if so if you get it it's it should be
the Unrated cut I don't even know if you
can get the one that was cut out of it
more but yeah so check it out if you
like that kind of thing and as always if
you like our show please like share
subscribe and share with all your
friends and family and everybody you
know cuz it really does help a lot if
you'd like to financially support the
show you can go to our patreon page at
patreon.com slash 13 o'clock podcasts or
you can go to our blog which is 13
o'clock podcast wordpress.com and
there's a link in the sidebar to a
PayPal account where you can make a
one-time donation also remember these
movie retrospectives right here come out
every Friday we also do 13 o'clock
matinee which is the three new movies we
saw on the theaters this past week that
comes out every Sunday and our regular
episodes that come out every Tuesday and
we will see you next time bye